attention peuvent se blesser et mon
souhait c ils vont y laisser faire mal
forcément mais bon je sais qu'on pouvait
être au chaud lula ouais faut continuer
à bosser à tous les mecs mois comme
c'est là tout se jouera pas garder de
tomber son contrat le plus distant
[Musique]
enfin jouer tout de suite tous ensemble
pour signer votre contrat
vasiliauskas cache-cache contrat c'est
bon on a caché vos contrats contempora
haïtien ce soir vous allez partir à deux
à chaque fois on a caché vos contrats
dans le hall
d'accord les chérit le premier qui me
ramène son contrat bibi ce sera validée
va valider va valider elle est validée à
les attentions
retour attention blessés trois sont des
gens de partout
rien dans ce contrat je crois qu'il est
dans une jarre au maintien oh non non
non il ya des [ __ ] de royal aux
mamans viennent
non ici ça fait quoi et quoi dedans mais
c'est pas toi elle a regardé terrible
axé votre contrat
il ya marqué les avoir c'est ça tu sors
ton contrat hier à nancy l'an passé mais
ya rien
sortons travel animaux attention vous
est donné mais malheureusement pour
l'instant contre vendenheim benhaim
regarder la société est un valet c'est
con ils ont fait l'erreur de ne faut pas
non c'est pas possible
[Applaudissements]
le prêt à laisser les choses aller vite
en tout cas ils vont vite en d2 jamais
vise à mieux pays d'asie qui trouve son
contrat est sous sa m zab elle
s'organise ont cherché partout partout
[Applaudissements]
km sur une personne ah ouais bah matures
une personne les chiottes alemao note
attention il est bien bien bien il est
oui ou non plus rien lâcher pour voiture
une personne ça peut être également dans
une plante dans une plante la déception
[Applaudissements]
bravo
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon on la retrouvera dans deux ans
c'est me parle alors les bons phone et
elle voit toujours pas la vallée
bouffonne a laissé une voix et noailles
agathe voilà gagner va la gagner
merci pour les bras 24 arbitres à gâteau
proulx et nova
malheureusement mes chiens y aura
d'autres occasions te plait pas je peux
pas je commençais attention on peut pas
se blesser vont se presser ils vont y
laisser faire mal forcément mais bon je
sais qu'on pouvait être celle où la whey
aussi à tous les mecs mois comme c'est
la cas ce jour à perdre et doit trouver
son contrat le plus difficle jean michel
prêtre
allez jean louis
[Rires]
la dame ou sarah départ
george hill ou gilles verdez j'ai mal
contre gilles verdez un contrat et est
validé bravo aussi à laura font
malheureusement givet jean-michel r on
n'a plus de nouvelles un verset
[Musique]